[Music]
foreign
has stayed hidden on Earth
the darkness has found us again
prime
this is about the fate of all living
things Unicron
is coming
foreign
[Music]
not a human here I'm nobody I ain't even
seen nothing I'm not even seeing
anything right now
this is not our war
Optimus we must trust each other to
protect the home we all share
how big can this guy be uh he eats
planets so like way bigger than a planet
in the end
everything you cared for
will be consumed
maybe there's another way to save our
home
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
please
[Music]
yo Noah Take the Wheel
yeah baby
foreign
[Music]
there is a Darkness coming okay
[__] yeah
it was all a dream
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
and if you don't know that you know
oh
it was all a dream the names
relax a mirage remember
and if you don't know
[Music]